good afternoon everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today his SCP 8 23 object
class Euclid special containment
procedures SCP 8 23 is to be secured by
no fewer than 6 on-site personnel until
such time as decontamination protocols
can be established and the artifact in
question neutralized personnel must
respect a 20-meter safe zone around the
currently established red zone at all
costs any individual civilian or not who
enters the established red zone is to be
terminated immediately by sniper fire
should music or piping be heard
emanating from within the red zone
foundation personnel on site are to
immediately Don protective earplugs and
withdraw from their positions to a 2
kilometer perimeter beyond the currently
established yellow zone an informed
foundation's scientific personnel
immediately following the realignment
event foundation's science personnel
will survey the area and determine the
boundaries of the new red and yellow
zones using procedure 823 - 1 alpha due
to the necessity of maintaining auditory
alertness no personal music devices or
radios aside from necessary equipment
are to be allowed at the observation
site description
as CP 823 is an abandoned theme park
located in sight was abandoned in after
several violent events resulting in the
deaths of park attendees a complete list
of set events is included in supplement
a 23-0 1-13 quote civilian deaths
attributed to SCP 8 23 SCP 8 23 was
finally abandoned after the events of
also known as Bloody Sunday when the
influence of the artifact in question
reached a 20-year peak 231 attendees
were killed and another seven injured or
maimed a complete list of casualties is
included in supplement 823 - 1 - 14
quote civilian deaths resulting from
event 8 - 23 - 99 Euclid but include two
individuals male and female fused
together at multiple points after
emerging from the tunnel of love dark
ride one individual wearing a happy
hippo mascot uniform found dead of
suffocation mouth trachea and lungs were
discovered to be filled with a fibrous
substance later determined to be
identical to the stuffing in said mascot
uniform dead 15 individuals recovered
from the thriller chiller roller coaster
all decapitated by blunt force witnesses
reported that the deaths did not occur
simultaneously but in groups of two
starting with the front row seats and
ending with the back forensic analysis
indicates that each set of deaths
correspond to a loop or turn in the
roller coasters tracks
dead one individual recovered from under
the thriller chiller roller coaster
dead of broken neck and massive cranial
trauma caused by a 50-foot fall from an
inverted position individual was seated
at the back of said roller coaster and
somehow managed to extricate self from
the right safety harness halfway through
the ride dead one individual found
dismembered inside the house of mirrors
attraction left arm was found sixteen
feet to the north from the torso left
leg was found inverted and attached to
the ceiling by sinews right leg was
found in the possession of subjects 79
partially consumed forensic analysis
indicates that teeth marks found on
flesh and bone of said leg are human in
origin to date no trace of right arm has
been found alive or complete record of
casualties please see supplement 8 23-0
1-14 civilian deaths resulting from
event 823 - 99 - euclid following said
event foundation mobile task force rose
71 origami toads was sent in to the site
to assess the situation and carry out
containment procedures MTF ro 71 was not
successful in determining the cause or
location of the deaths due to casualties
inflicted on team members see supplement
8 - 23 - 0 1 - 15 quote casualties among
MTF ro 71 resulting from event 8 23 - 99
- Euclid partial list of casualties
included MTF ro 71 commander cause of
death suicide caused by forced sexual
entry through left eye
resulting in unsurvivable brain trauma
agent cause of death suicide individual
was found with all ammunition
disassembled casings and bullets
discarded grams of propellant consistent
with the amount of disassembled
ammunition found on scene were retrieved
from individuals stomach and intestines
agent cause of death suicide individual
was discovered with lacerated lungs and
a broken jaw missing teeth were
retrieved from individual's lungs and
trachea for complete record of
casualties police seized supplement 823
- 0 1 - 15 quote casualties among MTF
row 71 resulting from event 823 - 99 -
Euclid following the deaths of 50% of
the mobile task force personnel on-site
supervisor ordered an immediate mission
abort containment protocol was switched
from retrieval to on-site securement
standard media blackout procedures were
carried out including addendum 823 - 1
re destruction of site per oh five level
order request for immediate destruction
of site by air strike is denied due to
proximity to civilian population lack of
plausible cover story scenario and
unknown nature of artifact in question
addendum 823 - to re red zone as of this
date SCP a 23 is undergone 3 realignment
events requiring resurvey of affected
zones apparent range of red zone has
increased in size by 5% during that time
rate of expansion appears to be
accelerating at a linear rate see report
823 - 2 - 7 quote result of 7th survey
of SCP 8 23 request upgrade to cutter
addendum a 23-3 re-up grade 2 Keter
denied by o-5 council reason
insufficient data to justify
reclassification I never liked theme
parks anyway anyway that about does it
for today thank you all for listening
and you are all dismissed goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gansu berry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]